at the time the world couldn't get
enough
of princess diana her decision to open
up
only fuelling further that demand only
now the build up
and the tactics used to encourage her to
talk have been uncovered
in 127 pages lord dyson forensically
details the questions asked at the time
and the cover-up in memos previously
seen by sky news it was clear the bbc
knew that martin beshear had fake
documents and lord hall
had spoken to him about it an interview
that dyson describes as woefully
ineffective the investigation he said
did not achieve its purpose
of getting to the bottom of what mr
bashir had done or why he'd done it
even a note from an internal meeting
said the diana's story
is probably now dead unless spencer
talks
ann sloman then acting head of weekly
current affairs admitted to lord dyson
that it sounds a bit like the mafia but
it wasn't meant that way
i promise you kilik was the panorama
producer who first
told the bbc about the forge documents
it was a difficult climate to work in
and when myself and others were faced
with the with the situation
of referring these documents out we knew
it was going to be difficult we knew it
wasn't
news that the bbc would want to hear
what we didn't expect
was a smear campaign a cover-up and
ultimately all to be sacked
but calls to the press office from that
time showed that other journalists had
been asking questions
about whether bashir had told diana she
was being spied on
dyson found that the bbc had covered up
such facts as it had been able to
establish about how mr beshear secured
the interview
he said that by failing to do so the bbc
fell
short of the high standards of integrity
and transparency
which are its hallmark 25 years on
the revelations have again undermined
that reputation
the cover-up is shocking i mean how can
the bbc accuse
government ministers or civil servants
or leaders of
public and private institutions of not
being transparent and
open with the public and are accountable
when they
they as a corporation have behaved in
this way
that's the that's the damaging part of
it the awards and the accolades were why
they wouldn't want anything to
overshadow what was described internally
as the scoop
of the century those closest to diana
believe it changed the course of her
life
but the interview put martin beshear in
pole position
for future projects he approached mark
bukowski
about an interview with michael jackson
when he represented him
in the uk he said look what i did with
diana it became a great event and she's
very
pleased at this point he brought out a
letter uh
a letter was on on kensington police
heading no papers i remember
um but it was certainly signed by adana
and read it and it was a fulsome praise
of him
and and the interview even if diana had
wanted to talk without the fake
documents
lord spencer would never have introduced
her to martin beshear
a meeting that he says stoked her
paranoia and mistrust
damage that no report or apologies can
ever
repair rihanna mills sky news